hello everyone hello hello I can't believe I streamed 10
hours of Hades yesterday if I if I knew that I was gonna do
10 hours of Hades I wouldn't have done a double stream today
yeah no I'm I don't know what the fuck was around with me I
was just like I was like surely I won't stream that long to
like Sure, I won't play Hades too that long, but that bitch
areas, man, I will always be a hater What's that saying go
if she has if she has 20 haters one of them is me if she has
one hater It's me if she has zero haters it's because I am
dead
I had to I was I had to I had to keep going Yeah, just,
just, no, I knew it wasn't going to be a short stream.
I just was, I just didn't know it was going to be a 10-hour
vibe.
Welcome to see a 10-hour vibe.
The more things change, the more they stay the same, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Be a hater even after death.
That's right.
If she has zero haters, it's because I'm dead and I'm a
ghost and I'm haunting her until she's dead.
immortal so haunt her forever um anyway you know fuck that
bitch um it's her fault that i end up streaming for 10 hours
so fuck her uh that was a tutoki also aries did nothing
wrong it was your fault for not oh let me dodge a 100 attack
damage boost yeah let me fucking dodge that real quick um mr
broken bond thank you for super chat thank you thank you
how's the tooth going um oh is that skin from my gums wait
it just came out of my mouth oh
okay a piece of okay that's not oh i was like what's that in
my mouth and i was like blah and i'm like oh that's skin
You're eating it.
Anyway.
Tuesday is my dentist's appointment.
So, well, I mean, I don't feel pain.
I don't feel pain right now.
From.
I don't know if it's food from this morning or if it was
from my gums.
So.
Uh, Tuesday is my dentist appointment, but update on my
molar, my back molar that I somehow might have accidentally
cracked.
Um, yeah, I hope someone cancels on Monday.
Um, it's okay.
Like, I don't feel any pain.
It's just like, I feel just like sometimes it's just, I
think my, I think my gum is swollen on that too.
I can't tell if it's my tooth or my gums Because it's all
the far back So far back It's like the very back tube So I
can't tell at all I really can't tell But I think it's I
think it's okay Stop touching it So So like I don't know I'm
not sure Lolly, do you have a super chat?
No, there's no blood.
There's no blood, guys.
There's no, just to make sure, just so you guys all know,
there is no blood.
Everything is fine in that area.
Yeah, it might be a filling came loose.
It could be a filling.
I know I did.
I did got a root canal on one of, I don't think it's that
two.
I don't know if it's that two.
Okay, so let me give you a history on what my parents did to
my teeth.
When I was very young, they enclosed my mom.
I think apparently now people don't do that anymore because
people were like, that's a pretty bad idea.
So instead of getting braces or, you know, other things that
kids normally go through, I never got braces.
Because what my mom did was, I told this story before, she
enclosed my teeth with silver.
I have no idea what that means But apparently nowadays
people don't do that anymore But my teeth was like enclosed
with like those silver fill Like I don't remember what it is
But like I basically had like silver Silver teeth and stuff
On my teeth So it's like silver fillings I don't know I'm
not sure what they're called anymore Um, you're so bougie.
So, um, so I never, I didn't really get, uh, I didn't really
get like actual like braces.
So I just did that to fix my teeth.
And I was like really, really young.
That's why I hated the dentist, um, when I was little.
Because like, um, I call it, but it's a crowd.
I don't know.
I don't remember what it was called.
Um, so it was just like the backstabbing.
Like it wasn't like the front teeth.
It's like the backs and everything So like my front teeth
was fine.
They just she just put like silver teeth on the back ones
And I think maybe it's the silver fillings finally coming up
because it's like been years So So I've always had like
trauma and PTSD from the dentist because My mom did that and
then I never went to the dentist after that But like I had
so many dentist visits for like I think like two to three
years of my life when I was really little.
But they like kept, because of that, they do those like
little, they do like those little, like, you know, like the
anesthesia where they numb your mouth and everything.
But it was so because I was a kid, right?
It was so fucking painful.
And I had to go to the dentist.
Like, I think like so many times.
I don't even remember.
It was so long ago.
But I had to go to dentist so many times as a little kid.
and they always had to yeah so i had like trauma from the
dentist because of that because they're always poking
needles in my mouth and it was so fucking painful and i
remember one time they fucked it up twice because i was so
scared i think i moved and they they like they like uh
punched it they put the needle in it in the wrong area so i
have to they have to like be like i need to use the bathroom
and i come because i was like oh they're done they did the
needle thing but because i moved they they put the needle in
the wrong area and then when i came back from the because
this was like trauma, you know?
And then it came back like, all right, we gotta do this
again because we did it in the wrong part of your mouth.
And I was like, what?
What do you mean?
You know, I didn't understand that because I was a little
kid.
I was like, what do you mean?
Did I not do it?
Like, did I not?
Did you not?
What do you mean yet?
So I was, I really, really am not a fan of the dentist
because of it, because I had to go to the dentist so many
times as a little kid.
Um, that like the especially the needle part it was just so
fucking painful as a child like now like I know like we like
when I went to dentist to get root canal a couple years ago
it didn't hurt as much as it did when I was a little kid
because I don't know I had more pain receptors in my mouth
back then now I'm more numb to the feeling of pain because
because I've had worse now like as a kid you know you never
had felt that pain before but now now I'm more numb to it so
so DFM, thank you for this super chat, thank you, thank you,
don't hear you silver too.
So I think one of the, maybe the silver filling finally
popped off of my molars.
I think maybe that's what happened.
So, because like, it's not, I don't know, I don't think it's
a, I mean, it could be a cavity, I don't know.
I don't think it's a cavity just because I don't feel any
pain from it.
So unless like, I don't know.
Unless, like, the nerve's fucking dead.
That's also a concern.
So I'm hoping, I'm hoping that the nerve's not dead.
And it's just, just the filling came out.
Just because I cracked it.
What did I eat?
I ate a steak.
My bad.
I, that's, I fucked up the, Here, I ate a steak and yeah,
that might have been why it got cracked a little.
Bro, of course you did.
I don't even eat steak that much, too.
That was the first steak I ate in like six plus months.
So I was like, I was like, y'all, y'all, y'all.
And I'm like, ah.
It was a good steak.
It was a fucking rhubarb, though.
Um, Pixel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Last time I talked about the dentist, I scared one of my
friends that was preparing mentally for months to go to a
dentist.
I felt so bad.
But I remember when I talked about getting a root canal.
That shit was, because like, I didn't know what a root canal
really was, but also, like, it was like five years ago.
And that shit scared, like, oh yeah, I remember I told you
guys.
It's because, like, I wish I still have the picture I drew.
But like, my root canal was my teeth.
I don't know if you guys remembered the story.
like remember it got for those who remember I got root canal
done a couple of years ago I don't remember this was like
from before I joined a corpo or was it after I joined a
corporal but um when I was getting my root canal done I
don't know if anyone remembered this story but the tooth
that had the root canal was so fucked up it was I remember
you guys if you remember the picture up because they're like
oh yeah you have three because like you know if tiff has
It's supposed to be two.
You know, it's supposed to be two like the two pinchers.
I think mine had three I think I don't know if you guys
remember the story, but mine had like three So it was like a
fucking alien like yeah, they had roots in the root canal So
it was like a fucking I'm not talking about the wisdom to
but like um it had three instead of two so so it was a
fucking mutant teeth that had a root that had to get a root
canal in and so like they obviously that means they had to
like kill off the nerves but it was so fucked up that it
made it even more painful than it should be just because it
had three instead of two i was like where did the extra lid
come from and why did it have to be this tooth like I was
like, I was just like, out of all the teeth, out of all the
teeth, teeth that's in my mouth.
The one I fucked up was the mutant one.
Anyway, Petra said, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The last two times, a feeling came out for me.
It was a sit.
You didn't happen to spit anything out and felt a cold air
vacuum sensation near that tube, did you?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think I just cracked the feeling.
feel a cold air sensation near it too like i'm sure i yeah i
don't feel it so i think it's like um i think it just
cracked it and then that's why like it feels weird because
obviously they're like why is there a fucking crack in my
body's like okay that's not supposed to happen um so i don't
know we'll see silver filling is tend to crack after 10 plus
years yeah i assume it's the filling because my molars are
the ones that got the silver filling not like the front part
it's just my molars so i think i think it's just age too
long um i just think it was super chat thank you thank you
immune dokey debut on marvel rivals when they was super chat
thank you thank you oh by the way guys check out the time
square uh for rivals day i'm i'm there they cut up okay so i
they cut up a lot of the video because i said in like my
video was like let's see 42 seconds long so if you guys are
like why does it feel like it's why does it sound so like
the cutting for it sounds weird because it was a 42 second
video because you're like remember to say this this okay
i'll give you guys extended cut i'm sad it didn't like let
me say hi i'm dokey bird but i appreciate they i'm asking me
to record something um but like i was like bro how come They
get to introduce themselves.
Why did they were just like happy anniversary?
Like, they just gave me a happy anniversary.
I was like, at least let me say it.
I'm Doki Bird.
I can't believe it's been a year.
Oh my gosh.
Hello, hello.
It's me, Doki Bird.
I'm here to wish my rivals a happy anniversary.
Yeah.
I'm like, okay.
And then I say a lot more after that.
I'm like, they could have just...
Like, they could have just said, Hello, hello, everyone.
It's me, Dokey Bird.
Happy at Marble Rivals.
Happy anniversary.
But then they cut the part where I say, I'm Dokey Bird.
But then I'm like, what the fuck?
The other people get to introduce themselves.
And it was so much longer.
I was just like, what the fuck?
And so I was just like, I was like, wait, where's my, like,
why can't I tell everyone I'm Doki Bird?
But no, I did send in a 42 second video, though.
I did send that.
But I do appreciate them asking me and adding me and you
were nominated.
That's why.
I mean, that makes sense to.
I do appreciate them adding me in and asking me to record.
something um i i definitely should have record said like i
definitely should have maybe recorded less because i gave a
42 second video um to be fair there was like a lot of
guidelines i thought i don't know i didn't really i didn't
realize like what kind of video they were making um maybe i
should have made it much more simple i i shuddered down i
definitely should have made it A bit more simple for sure.
Anyway, anyway, where was that?
Okay, so today we're going to be playing No Players Online.
For those who might be like, why does that game sound very
familiar?
A long, long time ago, it was like an, it was, I mean, it
still is an indie game.
But it was like a really short game uploaded on Ichio.
this game is because I it was a very um because a very
popular let's play video was made out of it like from game
grumps where um I think it was like Danny is like afraid of
horror games and then Aaron tricked Danny Dan to play uh to
play no players online and apparently it's it was like I
remember watching that video so I know I remember sort of
like I sort of remember the gameplay of So it's basically it
was like a horror game and it ended up being like an AR.
Yeah, I'm game grumps It was a horror game on game grumps,
but it didn't look like a horror game until like Surprise
like a fucking ghost shows up because it's no players online
and Suddenly a player was online, you know the prep like,
you know, it's sort of obvious To figure out the premise is
like no players online unless there was a player online And
so that's like the whole premise of the game.
And I remember watching that video.
And I was like, oh, that seems like a, I mean, it was a good
video.
And apparently a couple of weeks ago, a couple spoiled the
game.
Shake my head up.
Spoilers, Donkey.
How was I supposed to know?
It was, there was going to be a player online.
online, Doki.
How dare you spoil the plot twist?
And then apparently there was like a whole ARG made out of
that game.
So like, you know, for those who don't know what ARG is,
like there'd be like hidden messages and stuff scattered
around the web and people were trying to figure out like the
entire story of this game.
And apparently it was a huge thing.
I remember reading it on Wikipedia about the ARG and it
became a whole wild thing from it that stemmed for it.
Anyway, the full game just released a couple of weeks ago.
They made a full edition of this game.
I don't really know exactly what the full game brings.
But I did read a little bit of the reviews, and they did say
that it shifted from a horror to a mystery.
I guess to follow up with the whole ARG thing.
They made it more of a like, oh, what the fuck is going on?
So they did, like, add some mystery and drama to it.
So it's not just, like, a full-on horror.
So I feel like, you know, it'll be interesting.
Anyway, I hope Sound Guy is here to figure out the sound for
us.
All right, let's see.
No players online.
Yeah, so I don't know if there is jump scares or anything,
but, like I said, they apparently added more to the genre.
So it's not just horror now.
It's a mystery.
all right let's see is it hello are you not capturing my
game sir no players online hello oh my god don't tell me
okay there you go it just took a while english please angla
yeah
it's a thriller now it's not just a it's not just a horror
game it's a thriller
no players online but i'm on online I'm a player
oh okay let me FPS headbomb skip intro okay what kind of FPS
game is this if I can't adjust the sense immersion fails
whoa well that's loud I'm turning that down for us I don't
know if the sound guy is here but I'm just oh oh I remember
this okay this is familiar
Just like the original.
Oh, it's DVR on?
Sorry, my manager made this waiting room.
DVR is off now.
No more replay for all of you.
Alright.
Adam, but...
Okay, I remembered this.
I remember this from the original playthrough.
So it's basically capture the flag.
But like, just me.
With sound by Victor Cross.
Oh, wow.
Why is it red?
Oh, I'm just going to walk this way.
Oh, I can't.
I don't like that.
Oh!
How is that worse?
Okay, I'm okay.
My eyes!
Oh, shit.
It burns.
It's a little red, doggie.
It's...
It burns!
That's actually crazy.
Oh, shit.
That's an old-ass computer.
1960 to 1974.
Oh, my God.
We're on dial-up?
We're on dial-up.
Someone's using the phone right now.
Are you blind forever?
Oh, hello.
Um, last login.
Oh, there's a password.
I'm not John.
Oh, wait, eight months ago.
I guess I'm guessed.
All right, God.
Audio, graphics, effects, custom, or this reset game mouse.
No, I don't, my God.
Discord.
It, uh, what is Discord?
It's apparently 1993!
Alright, logging in as guest.
Alright.
Oh, this is interesting.
Oh, it's 1994 now.
Um, what's on my notepad?
If you read this, you'll get about.
out there you go now that's 1993 oh hey what's this mine's
equals 20 I'm just giving you guys the real 1994 classic
that's so true all right mine's 20 what's in here downloads
pictures okay i don't have anything in here also is sound
guy alive oh set to mines oh is it minesweeper oh my god it
is is this the game uh oh one two three okay oh gosh two oh
uh I remember how to play mine sweeper.
So it means there's two mines next to me.
Oh, shit.
Nice, I did it.
I assume this is the mine.
Right?
And it won.
And then so this.
Yeah, this is the mine.
So this should be fine.
And then this is the mine.
And this should be fine.
Oh my god, I can tell you.
I know how to play mine sweeper.
All right.
And then this is the mine.
And this should be fine.
Um, what would this be, though?
Let's see.
Oh, it should be these.
So, because, like, one, two.
And then, yeah, one.
All right, there.
Yeah, this should be on mine, so this should be fine.
And then, one, two, uh, let's see.
All right, one.
Okay.
one two so this should be fine and then i'm gaming guys i'm
gaming all right uh three okay four one oh my god stop stop
pc okay settings i need to fix this i don't like the i
really do not like this effect off there we go okay it
doesn't do anything okay okay different my never mind custom
desktop glitch okay what lens distortion get this out of
scan let's get the shit off save um excuse me i said no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no i don't
I'm trying to play mind sweeper.
I'm trying to play up.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to play mind sweeper.
Okay.
It's fine.
This is throwing my mind sweeper game right now.
All right.
One.
Okay.
One, two.
Thing is, it could be like here.
Okay.
It says one.
Oh, wait.
This is fine.
Two.
Okay.
So one.
One.
It'll be here.
So this should be fine because this is already.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm so smart.
All right.
So two.
Two.
One.
I assume.
Okay.
One.
Two.
Okay.
We'll do this.
One.
It has to be this.
So then this should be fat.
And then two.
One.
Okay.
Three.
One.
Two.
So.
Oh, God.
This one's hard.
One.
Two.
It has to be this or is this.
I assume it's this.
Because.
Yeah.
And then one, two.
So this should be five.
Yeah!
We did the quarter!
Alright.
Oh, hey, friend request.
Who's this?
I've been playing Mind Sweeper.
Add friend.
I don't know who you are, but I'll talk to a stranger.
It's impossible for my guests to only able to receive.
Okay, Quinn.
Wait, but he friended me.
Hello, Quinn.
hey hey bro hey what's who what who hello um hey oh my god
okay it's fine i have a virus apparently
it's stranger danger it's 1993 we don't know about strangers
yet i saw you online on the form and decided to add you i'm
on a guest account i want to play a game with you that
sounds creepy okay wait i'm just gonna continue my mind
sweeper um no no not in a creepy way okay why we do that
just like i don't really have any online friends that's sad
i'm sorry my condolences okay one okay okay the thing is
okay one so this should be fine because Uh, yeah, that
should be fine.
Okay, two.
Two.
Okay, one.
This is a bomb.
One.
Okay.
Two.
This should be fine.
Um.
Two.
Wait.
Okay, two.
Two.
Oh, this is.
is hard now i don't know where to go from here okay three
one two three okay one two three four okay one two three
four okay four got four here one two three one two three one
two
one two okay well this has one already so these two should
be fine all right okay one two oh i'm stuck here though one
two okay so i can clear the tile on this left oh do i oh
yeah one two three four this should be fine one two three
four and then one here but this is already a So this should
be five.
Oh, oh my god.
That scared me that that scared me.
I don't know that gave me a little jump scare I was
expecting that one.
Oh one two three.
All right.
There you go.
Don't worry.
We can talk soon We just gotta That's a real jump scare
Let's see one two three Okay One of these is a bomb.
Which one is it?
one of these is a bomb oh wait it's this it's this one my
friend all right one two three it's this one two three one
two one okay one two three okay one two it's these two one
two
Okay, one, two, three.
One, two, three.
Okay, now I'm stuck here.
Oh, no.
This is bad.
This is really bad.
I don't know how I'll get past this.
Mind Sweeper is more, okay, fine.
Okay, so what game do you want to play?
If I could tell them, I'd be playing Mind Sweeper.
The bottom three here?
shit really the lower left three but these are but I don't
know which one has the bomb though which one has the bomb
it's still up so we can play it bro the top left corner of
three but no there's one bomb here hmm oh here okay wait one
two three this is not a bomb oh my god this is getting
riskier and riskier by the second
there's a bomb here somewhere but i don't know where three
which one okay okay one two three one two three don't worry
i'll answer him back soon this is more important guy okay
now it's all random this is bad this is the real thriller
now oh okay okay okay okay all right i i made it i i made it
we're in the true heart okay oh no tensions are high now of
the lowest two the top two of the lowest two?
Are you sure there's two?
One of these is a bomb.
One of these two is a bomb, guys.
Two left of the lower two.
This one?
This one.
Oh, top left?
Guys, I'm scared.
This is not safe.
That is not safe.
This is not safe at all, guys.
This does not bring me safety.
I'm scared.
Two tiles above the one are empty.
Here?
There's no way.
Oh,
oh, that was scary.
Okay, okay.
Okay, that one was scary Okay, that's the bomb then Okay,
that was Fucking scary Okay, one, two, three That's fine
One, oh, come on, guys Come on, guys
Oh, are you serious?
I have this corner now Bro, this game is so tense Oh, no Oh,
no First on the farm.
This one?
You think this is safe.
Guys.
Right here.
Yeah?
No?
No.
Yeah.
Here?
You think this is safe.
There's no way this is safe.
It's a 50-50.
That's a boom.
Oh, no.
Cut the red wire.
Which wire is it, guys?
Oh, my God.
The tension.
The fucking tension.
Above three.
Blue.
The red, blue, or red.
Okay, guys.
Which wire do we cut?
Red, green, or blue?
Oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh, I cut the blue wire.
Oh, that was tense.
That was tense.
Who the fuck said green?
Who said the green wire?
I am the bomb expert.
What would you do if I was the bomb expert?
Okay, one, two.
Okay.
Oh, no.
This is safe.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Three.
Oh, okay.
One, two, three.
That should be all the bombs.
Wait, no.
That's not.
That's not all the bombs.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe the...
Oh, it's not The game would just be like, there you go.
Oh, shit, this is the bomb.
Okay, this is the bomb.
One, two.
And then one, two, three.
So this is safe.
And then one, two.
This is the bomb.
Oh, God.
Okay, I'll talk to my friend now.
Okay.
I need to fix this.
I cannot.
I don't understand why they do this to me.
I don't like the desktop shit.
I think if the desktop was not shaking, I'd be fine.
Get this out of my screen!
And the desktop glitch, too.
There.
Desktop shake.
Needs more shake.
There we go.
Low.
Alright.
There we go.
Okay, I should have just put it on low.
Alright, let's look at the audio player.
Oh, I don't have to.
have anything over the internet establishing connection to
the world i all right give me a sec i'm dialing up
well i have to connect to the internet first oh my god 3,000
31,200 bps oh my god what's in my bookmarks welcome to where
i connect what's on the news right what's on the world's
chat oh that's just my friend what's on today's news cannot
connect okay it's 13 degrees.
I'll go on the website.
What did I download to?
Oh, I don't have anything downloaded yet.
What was an announcement?
Thank you for 800 members.
Alright.
So it's just a simple shooter game.
Stupid.
Okay.
No, no.
It's like a capture the flag.
Where can I get the game?
I am loading it too fast.
i'll send the link i'll make a room just make a room and
i'll join you okay okay alpha test welcome thank you for
taking an interest in the alpha test of our game what if i
on is there anything else here update on post disappearing
the location where a server caught fire this caused my post
to disappear we apologize for the inconvenience i know some
are still visible but can't be open does this also have to
do with the fire effects of Jesus Christ you really think a
fire could do that wake up a fire doesn't choose what it
destroys it just destroys locking posts Jason warning for
spreading misinformation locking posts open your eyes frogs
open your eyes sheep okay what else do they have post
introduction here is it just the where's my form release and
work in progress fishing with nas oh that sounds fun are you
gonna play the best game wow it's very don't care it didn't
ask oh it's jason where could i download fishing with nas
there's not you're so stupid there's no fishing with nas one
then why is there a two in the title my market analysis has
shown me that People love the sequins.
I like the game a lot.
The explosions when you kill a fish are a really nice touch.
How do you change the shop icons when a player buys
something?
Also, was it difficult to make the swimming animations?
Was there a reason you chose four directional movements
instead of A?
Too long.
TLDR.
I'm too busy building my franchise.
All right, let's download.
What I need?
Oh, wait, I'm downloading Fishing with Niles too.
Bro, Jason sounds like a cool guy.
Jason the Super Dev.
But I'm playing this game.
Extracting right now?
Bro, I can't wait.
Guys, do you think the Maze Fishing with Knives 6 yet?
I've been waiting for that for a while.
Alright.
Let's play Fishing with Knives.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That's right.
Fishing with Knives!
Let's let you go!
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of stats for this one.
Okay, when can I redeem my fish?
Oh, wait.
I did it.
I'll have more air now.
Savvy.
Triple A guarantee.
I don't understand why this game is not popular.
Bro, I'm literally fishing with knives.
What more can I want?
Bro, this game has everything.
thing.
Okay, I need a hundred points to fish more with knives.
Oh, the deeper I go, the bigger the fish.
Oh my god, this takes forever.
Okay, guys, I need a stronger knife.
And stab, stab.
It has fishing and it has knives.
What more can a guy want?
Okay.
Don't worry, I almost got there.
Nice.
Not 200.
Does it upgrade my knives?
At all?
Sure, I would like knife upgrades.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, oh my god, that's a shot.
Wait, I need that.
Okay.
But that's a stronger gun.
Nice.
Okay.
That's a stronger knife.
Let me go.
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh my god, I can do double kill too with this.
Oh my god, look at the explosions, guys.
Okay, we gotta get a gun.
I think that's a gun, right?
Oh, my God.
Get out of here, fish.
Get out of here!
That's right!
The fisherman is here!
Eventually, I'll play this.
My friend is still waiting for me.
I'm like, I'm sorry, bro.
I'm gonna play fishing with knives, bro.
You understand, right?
fish fear me women fear me too I don't know why is it
because of my knife gun
there you go and that's enough for the next upgrade I'm
pretty sure okay it's 500 don't worry I got this but I keep
farming nice nice I got it oh my god wait I think the second
one is like an actual Fucking sword.
There you go.
Oh my god, I'm fucking bragging right now.
Oh my god, that's a goddamn great white shark!
That's fucking right!
Not even sharks are safe from me!
Okay, I need a thousand.
The game has levels!
For him.
Guys, is this sound too loud?
Wait, I have enough.
Alright, here we go.
I just have enough.
Oh my god, it can go even higher.
That's right.
I got enough now.
Get out of here, sharks!
Bam!
Not even sharks are safe.
That's fucking right.
Wait, where's the oxygen tank?
There we go.
All right, more oxygen.
I did not expect this game to actually be good.
But I think I can play this game instead of whatever capture
the flag shit this random stranger wants to play with me.
Like, who the fuck plays capture the flag 1v1?
Like, what?
Bro, that's dumb.
Bro, I have like three, two more friends, bro.
I'll just make it a 2v2.
Find two more random friends on the forum.
Can't be that hard.
You found me.
me
like if it's just like a 1v1 lobby then that's fine but bro
wants to play capture the flag 1v1 like bro fine if you
found if you randomly added me you can find two more you can
find two more people on the port oh my god I think I did it
I think I beat the game I think it's just sharks sharks was
end game Bro, it's just nukes.
I'm just firing nukes right now.
Okay, I beat the game.
At devs, not enough content.
Thumbs down.
Yeah, you might have made a free game, but I beat it in like
less than five minutes.
Thumbs down.
Go deeper?
I can't.
This was the deepest I can go.
Wait, I think?
Oh, wait, I think I can go deeper.
I demand more levels!
Okay, wait.
Let's see if I can go deeper.
Yeah, see, this is the furthest I can go.
Unloughed you.
I can't really open this.
It's just a similar game, but play it.
But your last cost, here you go.
To move space to stab.
Okay, resources.
Graphics shops.
You actually have, like, the whole PNG of the thing, too.
Oh, that's cool.
Alright, what am I supposed to download again?
Wait, let me...
I need to see if I can...
I'm so mad.
I hate that goddamn glitch effect.
Oh!
Don't understand.
I don't want any of this.
Off!
Maybe I log out and log back in.
It'll do it.
Okay, there you go.
Log in.
This old-ass computer.
Alright.
Did it fix it?
Okay, whatever.
I don't care.
I'll talk to them.
I gotta restart the PC, guys.
All right, download.
Oh, it's fishing with knives.
Oh, sorry, I went back to fishing with knives.
All right.
Oh, read me.
Thank you for downloading.
Don't forget to leave feedback on the form.
Service may be unstable.
Let us know you're having trouble hosting the room.
It's in it.
Okay.
All right, let's play this game that they want me to play.
Oh, okay.
Create room.
Set room.
1v1 me noob.
Set room size.
Two.
Set map.
All right, off.
There we go.
All right, there's two of us.
You just say he'll 1v1 me.
Okay.
I created the room.
Why is he not joining my room?
Wait, where is the map?
Where's the fucking...
Where's the flag area?
I'm lost already.
What?
Oh, okay.
That actually freaked me out.
I was like, what the fuck?
How do I get to the other side?
Oh, here.
Hello?
Is no one online?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Hello.
Oh no, I was...
He was supposed to join my room.
He said create a room and then join it.
Oh, oh that scared me.
I don't know if it's too loud or not.
It's not too loud, right?
That boom Scared me a little.
Okay, it's this way.
How many bullets do I have?
It doesn't even say.
Bro, this game...
This game is poorly designed.
This FPS game?
How the fuck am I supposed to know how many bullets I have?
Oh, I'm lost.
I am lost.
Oh, no.
Where am I?
How do I get to the other side?
Okay.
I already forgot how this map was designed.
Is it this way?
No, this is where I got the flag.
No, it should be like here.
Wait, how many bullets do I have?
I have a lot of bullets.
I don't think I need a reload, guys.
The only issue is that I don't have the...
Don't have a crosshair.
What the fuck?
Did not go on the other side from here?
I thought I went to the other side from this way.
It's so dark.
Oh no, it's from here.
Wait.
Guys, I need a HUD.
It's so poorly designed.
I need a fucking HUD.
Don't worry, I'll win this game.
one point look at that i win oh there he is there my friend
joined hello he's here
hello friend look friend is here that's right you gotta
fucking win this game i have one point already.
What are you gonna do about it?
Huh?
Yeah, see?
Where are you gonna do about it?
We have one minute left.
How would this one be one?
He just needs to show up to grab the flag and I'll be like,
pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Reload.
Come on, where is he?
Grab the flag, pussy.
I win these.
Come on, one minute to get here.
I'm not trying to...
No, don't tell me to look behind me.
I know I...
There's no way.
See?
It's safe.
I don't need to look behind me.
That's right.
He's lost too, just like me.
He's also lost right now.
bro where are you at bro come on you wanted to play this
game
don't with me guys no i'm actually scared to look behind me
i'm oh what's that oh i want to cap this i don't want to
look behind surely he's right in front of me right sure oh
my god
where is he where is this i'm going to win the game
fucking new can't even find my map huh
what what
do you mean overtime I've won excuse me um um did I not win
question mark
no music that's right you're not gonna distract me with
music
I don't understand but I won did I not win the game hello
bam bam bam
where is he Where did he go?
Oh, I'll grab another flag.
Stupid.
Oh, why is that glowing red now?
Oh, I don't like that.
Hello?
Is that a friendly red?
Surely it's friendly, right?
Right?
Hello?
Oh, see, yeah, I knew it was friendly.
I told you guys, it was a friendly red.
Bro, is this guy hacking?
Bro, are you in the fires?
Hello?
Well, maybe I should have kept the record player playing.
Oh, maybe that was a mistake.
Guys, I think I should have kept, at least it was sound.
At least it would have been a nice song to listen to.
Dude's no clipping, yeah.
I might have messed up, guys.
I should have kept the music going.
Because at least it'd be like, you know.
He-he-ha-ha music playing while we play this game.
Oh, mistakes were definitely made.
Oh, I don't like this.
What?
Hello?
Okay, okay, there we go.
There we go.
It was jammed.
I got it.
I got the shot.
I got the shot, guys.
what the hell is that you my new friend who told me to play
this game okay i got three flags now okay this guy this guy
is fucking he's fucking walling he's no clipping he's Oh,
oh, okay.
Oh, okay, bro.
Oh, just because I am winning the game.
You're gonna...
Oh.
Well-time mistakes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, he's such a sore loser.
He all f4ed my game.
Submit feedback.
I want to give you guys a 10 release to submit it.
He's been affecting our team.
This feedback forum has been closed.
Oh my god.
They literally closed the reviews.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
It was spyware, wasn't it?
Oh no.
He made me installed malware, didn't he?
I'm hacked.
I'm hacked now.
He's in my PC.
I fucking knew.
I knew you guys never accept random AIM friend requests.
Now to take my shop, the Geek Squad.
They fished that.
They got a cookie grabber.
Oh.
Just because he lost in a video game, he gave me malware.
Oh, now I got the blue screen.
Geek Squad isn't prepared for this.
Alright.
Should be fine.
Right?
This is my family PC.
So, like, my dad's gonna be really angry if he can't go on
his favorite websites and his Excel sheets.
Guys.
My dad does tell me.
taxes on this PC he's gonna be really angry if you can't oh
well don't guess I can't be guessed no more oh oh oh it's
just gone now okay it's just it's just gone now oh what who
oh I guess that's how do I S E N T I am okay I guess that's
how I do the password.
S-E-S-E-S-E-N-T-L.
Is that an L or an I?
L, M, E, E-N-T-A-L?
It's not Boo!
I don't think the ghost is sending me boobs Log in double
check and try or is it her is it Sarah I'm fucking no
s-e-n-t-i-m-e-n-t-a-l how is that wrong
Sent oh
Sentimental.
There you go.
What did I type?
Oh, I put an L instead of an I.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, well, nice.
There's PCs.
This is my dad's PC.
Oh, yeah.
My friend.
All right.
Play the real game.
one two one one so this is fine and then this is fine and
one two one okay one this is a bomb one This is fine.
Okay, one, two.
One, one, two.
Okay, okay, one.
This is a bomb.
So this here is fine.
One, this is fine.
This is a bomb.
This is fine.
Oh, I'm so good at this now, guys.
One.
There you go.
I need to figure out...
Okay, this is a bomb, so this should be fine.
This should be fine.
Oh, I'm speeding through this now, guys.
I'm actually gaming now.
Bomb.
Fine.
Oh, wait, wait.
Okay, now I don't know.
Now, I'm a pro.
Oh, one, bomb, bomb, one, two, three.
One, two, three.
Okay.
Fine here.
There we go.
Bomb, bomb.
This is fine.
Bomb, bomb, bomb.
Bomb.
One, two, three.
Bomb, bomb.
Fine.
Oh.
Bomb.
Fine.
Yeah!
I'm so good at that.
this game okay let's actually let's actually read 1 46
seconds 2 52 seconds 3 55 seconds how many did i do it god
i'm such a pro fixed geometry missing in pool schedule
meeting to design forest post update on progress since alpha
oh this is the wait is this my dad's game welcome back john
wait Menta, menta.
Oh.
It's not the same.
Oh, it is.
Wait, that's the game.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I forgot.
Oh, that's not.
I didn't mean to play the game.
Oh, exit.
I want to look at what else he has on his PC.
I'm digging around his PC.
Soul transfer.
Excuse me?
Already installed.
Is this another new game?
connecting the penta star sigil server at 187.34 okay oh
okay i have an empty host now guys what what the bro oh my
bro i can't believe that the satan i can't believe satan
decided to like put soul tracks for online guys so Yeah, all
developers have this to get through the day, you know?
Gotta have a little soul transfer before you start coding.
Digital dark art.
Oh my god, okay.
Soul transit notes, all right.
Missing signatures.
Oh, pen to start dumping souls.
Match up open, crash combinations.
Found a way to proper transfer, graphical assets to new...
games damn even the devil yeah even the devil went digital
guys finally finally i can i can do i soon i hope they get
an app made you know to make it more convenient don't you
just want to make deals with the devil on the on the app you
know it's like uber eats but uber souls play around with a
soul essence it's it's terrifying what it can do We'll need
to find a way to intercept the souls before they altered the
game, allowing to create the game myself.
Finish the custom edge and connected it to the infuse tab.
I'm now able to intercept the souls before they get their
hands on my game.
With the editor, I can use the soul mechanics.
How I please.
What the fuck is this game?
Yeah.
Double dash delivery.
Good.
Maybe one.
We're all just waiting for the day.
Satan comes out with the new app.
Just to make it more convenient.
convenience now right seems can only exist when external
influence the mechanics and visuals remain mine to use
though which is the most important part confirm that
destroying game soul through my editor doesn't influence the
original game in any way good thing otherwise a lot of games
were already been destroyed I noticed older versions of the
prototype have lost their soul create a new version of the
game seems to destroy the previous soul of the game you need
to research more oh my god what the fuck so like every add
on to this game that he does, um, has a soil in it.
File Explorer.
What does he have?
Oh, hey, that's mine.
Wait, that's my files.
Wait, Scara?
I guess that was her pictures.
There's Sarah's pictures.
Update menu looks confusing.
Mine's equal.
20.
That's cute.
He has serious pictures in here.
I guess I play the game now.
Oh, I can't move this.
But I have anything else in the browser?
Why is he bookmarked?
Oh, John Mollard.
I'm saying on this blog to post updates about my work,
expect mostly in-progress screenshots and ramblings on games
I'm working on.
For the few who ran into this Vlog?
Don't know me?
Here's a little introduction.
I'm John.
During the day, I'm a student at night.
I work on... Yeah, little hobby game projects.
Yeah, including soul transfer.
Yeah, very, very little.
I've been doing this for about half a year now, so my game
design skills are not great.
Yeah, no, that's crazy.
I like how it's like little...
hobby games.
And also the dark arts, you know?
What a great hobby.
Okay, hello block, clock game.
Because I'm not far.
I had trouble with my weird system.
But I think it really played out.
I hope you enjoy it.
Alright, what's this?
Yeah, I can't wait for their new DLC Blood Sacrifice.
Alright, clock game version 1.
what's in clock game look at the time
okay time has stopped win back the hours by racing the hour
hand swing the pendulum back and forth to make the minute
hand take a full circle before the back hand reaches he make
it to midnight swing swing pendulum big swings take longer
but make stupid game.
Let's go.
That's right.
I'm gonna win.
Can't catch me.
On the high octane gameplay.
I wonder why this game never took off, guys.
It has everything.
The adrenaline rush as you race against the clock.
Yeah!
Level 2?
Oh my god, there's a level 2.
How many levels are there?
That's right.
I'm so confused.
What is this game about?
No players online.
It's just me.
I'm just on the PC.
by myself.
Okay, no, this game sucks.
I'll leave a review to say your game's trash.
The game fucking sucks!
I want to leave a review right now!
No, it's this.
I took a long to finish this one.
Lots of bugs because the engine is still in an early state.
I want to review bomb his games.
All right, dungeon blade.
Maybe this game is better.
Yeah, no wonder there's no players in these stupid games.
Dungeon blade.
Maybe you shouldn't say this to the guy who's transferring
souls.
What is he gonna do?
Transfer my soul?
Good luck with that.
I'm behind the computer screen.
I'm VPN on.
He doesn't know where I live.
You can't transfer my soul.
They trap you and all you have to do is your trusty blade.
You must escape.
Battle your way to freedom through a tricky dungeon full of
coolish flows.
Featuring state of the art, three-dimensional graphics.
Space, move forward, left, and right.
All right.
Maybe this game will be better than what the clock thing.
They trap you in the dungeon.
All you have, you must escape.
All right.
Dungeon Blade.
Oh shit.
Bam!
That's right.
Oh my god, I wish they used WASD.
Wait, it's just the same level.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, this is a wizard!
Oh no, I'm taking damage!
Damn, this is...
This is a hard game, guys.
Oh my god, it's the bats again.
Does this just repeat itself over and over?
How would I ever get out?
Oh, wait, no, this is a new room.
Oh, shit, there's a fucking skeleton!
Oh, no, what do I do?
Oh, my god, he's hitting me.
No!
I'm reviewing bomb.
I'm reviewing bombing this game because I died.
It's not because I was bad at this game.
It's because this game sucked.
it's been a while i've got married her name is sarah and
she's an artist her work is really incredible here's a
picture i've quit my position as a researcher and moved to
berlin with sarah i started a game company it's called
together so my colleagues are busy expanding work on the
shooter game oh this is the game that he's been doing oh
this is when he stopped doing it
all right game journalist mode it's not because I was bad at
this game.
It's because it sucked.
There's a difference.
Oh wait.
Can I talk?
Oh, I should talk to him.
I should talk to him.
And be like, where the fuck were you, Quinn?
Yeah, I'm here with a game journalist review.
It's not because I was bad.
It's because the game just didn't cater to me.
Who's this guy?
Any progress on the no clip plug?
It's incredibly hard.
I'll check around to see if anyone recorded the video.
told you.
This guy was cheating.
Fucking knew it.
Alright, Quinn.
Oh, there's this guy, is.
It's here.
We've discovered any bugs.
Hey, John, how's development of the game going?
Me and some of the people are still playing the Alphabash
and are loving it.
Can't wait for another official playtest.
Okay.
Who's Winston?
I played your game on Beyond Request, and it's miles ahead
of its competition.
3D graphics?
I mean, wow.
Let's sit down sometime if and talk about working together
i'm available this friday i'm also available this friday hey
john just checking back in with you maybe you missed my last
message we'd love to talk about what we can offer hey john
you out for the office for the well this is like me when
people have been messaging me sorry when i get so
overwhelmed it's like my discord messages
oh i'm unable to start chat
really like the alpha test you should stop doubting me i'm
sorry any plans for release you just have to put that to
good use all right all right now i think you can play all
right
there we go any servers the servers create game oh wait this
is new server name if you hack i report Two.
No.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Look, I'm just trying to do the path.
That'll stop them.
Good old 1993.
Wait a minute.
Oh, it's the pathway.
Oh, hey, it's that scary now.
Got him.
Oh, it has sound effects now.
Oh, wait, this version is like a more polished version.
It has sound effects.
Look.
Huh.
Look at that.
Oh, I have to wait for players to start the game.
Boo!
Hello, is anyone in here?
up there's.
Um, yeah, this is a programmer's PC.
Of course it's strong.
Guys, I have, like, 2 megabytes in this PC right now.
Not to brag or anything.
Yeah, 2 whole megabytes.
Exactly.
Damn.
groundbreaking I know that's like two million bytes exactly
where the fuck is where are the players someone play with me
that must have cost like three hundred dollars hello any
players online I'm gonna I swear to you I'm gonna do it
back.
You're not going to go in bathroom break.
Maybe someone will show up.
I'll be right back.
Many.
But so, Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Any players went online?
There's still no players online?
Where are the players?
Am I even supposed to be here?
I swear to God, this is like, oh my God, this is where the
puzzle is, isn't it?
Oh.
Wait, I...
Wait, there was?
What happened?
They just left.
They said hi, but no one answered.
Oh, is it because I put a password?
Oh, maybe that's why.
Okay.
I'll create another game.
He said a gamer word and got bad.
I'll call you.
Sarah all right there you go here you go surely someone will
join now right look I named the room after my wife anyone
here now what if I just oh I just respawned okay cool oh I
can fast travel with that
name of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Does anyone want to play?
I have an empty room right now.
Hello?
Do you want to join my room?
Any room joiners?
Can I do like one play and then I just play by myself?
Yeah, I got the speedrun tech locked in now i don't
understand why no one wants to play with me
hello oh oh wait now i don't have okay this has less bugs
this this build has less bugs he fixed all the problems i
have with the last build see like i have i don't have
unlimited ammo now did we did i download the wrong path
Maybe I download the wrong patch, you know?
Everyone's on, like, 1.3, and I'm on 1.2.
Maybe that's why.
You know, it's not because I have no friends.
It's just, like, you know, I just have the wrong patch
downloaded.
I feel like I...
I feel like this is a puzzle.
Yeah, I'm on Overwatch 1.
Not patient enough.
Fuck this.
I'm pretty sure this is a puzzle I have to figure out.
Is it a soul transfer?
Am I supposed to transfer a soul right now?
John!
Alright.
I'm gonna go transfer a soul real quick.
Okay.
Oh!
Game one!
What a game.
Transfer soul.
Oh no?
Not mine, feel?
Oh, is it one of the games I downloaded?
Let's see.
What were my other games I downloaded?
I fucking knew it.
Alright, what other souls did you infuse in your game, sir?
Maybe dungeon blade.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there was a soul in that game?
Okay.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Alright.
Oh.
How do I play it?
Alright.
That's not cool.
Oh.
Looks like a fun game.
I did it.
I beat the game.
Is that how you guys do game development?
Oh.
This is how game development works, guys.
Okay, that should have been over.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Oh.
How the fuck?
Okay.
Nice!
I did it!
Oh my god.
How the fuck?
Okay, how the...
Okay.
I'm faster than this.
There we go.
I told you I'm faster.
Okay, I didn't realize there was more.
Um...
Okay, I am faster.
I have the button-in-mash power.
God damn it.
How did I do it?
There we go.
That's how I did it.
Okay.
I have a perfectly good explanation for this.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Okay.
Nice.
How many fucking...
Alright.
This is a bad game.
Can I move?
Can I put another game in here?
Separate.
This is a bad game.
Maybe I'll put clock tower in.
Transfer so.
Bro, I don't think game development is it for this guy.
I think he's gotta stop.
Oops.
Wait, I don't need a transfer.
Honestly, think maybe you should start a new career.
I don't think game development is it.
What the?
Okay.
The green wire!
Nice, I did it.
I saved the world.
It was that easy.
I won the game.
I beat the game, guys.
I did it.
It's always the green wire.
Watch this.
Apparently it's not always the green wire.
Wait!
Is it because it's not evil enough?
Is it because the game isn't evil enough?
I can only transfer it with...
Wait, is it?
only transferable with...
Wait, where's the other game?
What is this?
Wait, does that mean I can put fish with knives in there?
Oh, no, I can't.
What do I do now?
Wait, can I put a picture in it?
Maybe I put Sarah's picture in here.
No?
Alright, John.
What other games have you made?
Alright.
What other He only made two games.
What else can I transfer?
He's only made two.
Not even, like, good games out of there.
Not even two good games.
That's similar enough souls.
Place the vessel in the middle of the slot.
Place a fitting cell.
Press soul essence from the soul will be infused into the
vessel game.
Opening game immediately will allow the server to do
whatever they want.
It's best to open the game through the editor and implement
mechanics.
What the fuck?
Vessel.
Where the fuck is the game?
Okay.
Is this what you guys do?
Is this coding?
Am I coding?
You're confused.
Is this what coding is?
What's the fitting stone to correct us to that?
I don't have another stone.
Where are all the stones?
These are all just stupid notes.
Infuse.
Wait, that is how he code his game.
No use in playing with souls.
Who did he murder?
Where did this guy go?
get all these souls and then destroys the souls in the prop
bro okay one soul is visual oh my imagine your soul is being
used for a shitty ass game like that sucks bro
they took your soul and you were made for a shitty ass
capture the flag game some fucking golden eye rip off too
that's the worst part your soul was used to make a golden I
rip off who became mind sweeper
yeah I oh man it took my soul and I'm an AI gotcha slop game
yeah imagine they took your soul and you're made into those
like phone app games the fucking was that a garden game I
don't have I don't have any more stones in here john you're
not helping at all great game that behave unlike any of the
gameplay is much more abstract unusual and no story i'll
suddenly have a story tell me highly unusual are the souls
trying to communicate continue playing the game transformed
into the stone the game crash and the icon transformed into
a stone right in front of my eyes i'll do more research of
this stone but it seems very stable oh it's inconsistent
with the glitches but the song is calm to potentially use.
Before, I can assume they contain the souls of the original
games, but it's much more than that.
I think it's their pure essence.
Create a rudimentary version of what would be the infuse
tab.
Use the stone into a simple game I made.
It's unbelievable.
I had all the stone mechanics rambling placed throughout.
It's as if these souls created their own gameplay.
What the fuck?
What is going on?
Did I finish the bomb dungeon blade for a stone?
Oh, maybe.
Alright.
I guess I'll infuse this.
Maybe I'll get a stone out of it.
Do I have to finish their mini-game to get a goddamn stone?
Yeah, I did the...
Because, like, these two games didn't combine.
Yeah.
I have to combine, like, these games.
Wait, what?
Oh, they're not combining anymore.
Oh, that's weird.
Where's my mind sweeper?
Oh, no.
Where did my mind sweeper go?
I don't know where I...
Oh, it was mind sweeper?
Wait, where did I put mind sweeper?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
I have four games.
Wait, I can also have fish with knives, too.
Wait, maybe I can combine fish with knives with minesweeper.
Oh my god, what game, what beautiful game am I gonna get
from this?
Alright.
Oh, oh yeah, I don't know what I expected.
Oh wait, no, I'm alive.
It's fine.
I'd have to go down.
Fishing with mines.
I can hit everything.
I mean, it would be easier if I just went down.
What the fuck?
Oh.
I mean, it doesn't really matter.
Like, I'm tanky as hell.
Whoa.
Don't worry, I can tank it.
Yeah, I did it.
I beat the game?
Oh.
There's a dog Oh Hello
Okay I got goosebumps from that Hello Oh Oh Okay Um Did I
got a Oh okay Oh okay Okay
was that a dog's soul like um so whose soul was that
uh i don't know whose soul i just got from that
try fusing a fuse app with another app let me see if there's
any other games
All right, I'm going to see if I can go into someone's
else's games.
Releases and work in progress.
Tracked 20 summer days.
All right, new release.
Find love, survive, new translator from the original Korean
release.
Oh!
A dating sim!
I wonder how many souls are in that game.
All right.
We have a dating sim game.
Put it all here.
This is how I organize my.
files i think it doesn't work bad crack don't download this
trash wait no what i was looking forward to it what do you
mean i was looking forward oh i wanted to play 20 summer
summer days
key?
I didn't read it.
I just went straight to downloading.
Alright, well at least some work in progress.
What was the key?
Untested.
They're totally ultimate OTP forever.
But what is an OTP?
Okay, crack.
20 summer days.
Region unlocked.
X-Roe.
love cracked untested what the fuck wait what is the license
key it's less like it was in the it was in the files i
didn't read it by 20 summary days crack oh key gen oh my god
a key gen i can't believe it okay five fives oh my god an
hatch okay this is like crazy five five six eight seven nine
zero one five Yeah!
That's so real.
Sometimes in the afternoon.
Why I think it was a good idea to sign up for the summer
program.
My name is Park 23 years old.
I'm a master student in the true sense of the word.
The more viruses.
I mean this PC is already fucked.
So have all the malware fight each other.
it's summer i find myself once again in the classroom next
summer i should just focus on myself spend some quality time
doing nothing for a change and wait i forgot to write my
thesis next year okay these are worries for later let's try
to sit through this class first and press yellow use the
space bot to interact with the story element oh my god oh
this is so old school i think this guy is dosing off mr
science going over the same chapter we did last week i think
nobody has the courage to tell him.
Right.
Oh, window.
Looks like it's pretty messy.
I'll probably ring later if this is still in succession.
I'm so sleepy.
I shouldn't have gotten that dorm room.
It's always so loud there at night.
At least it's nice and quiet here.
Maybe I can just close my eyes for a little bit.
Oh!
Wake up, sleepyhead!
Oh, is that the love interest?
I'm in your class and in an hour go, silly.
Shoot, did I just slip through the whole class?
Oh, I don't know about you, but I'm heading out.
I like to hang out around in empty classrooms.
That's your business.
Tee-hee.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
Who is that?
I don't think she's in my class.
She's kind of cute.
Anyways, I should head out before it starts raining.
I swear to you guys, I play through 20 days.
The cicadas drown out the sound on the road behind me.
Stepping up from the air-conditioned building, hit with a
sweltering humidity luckily the log in front of the entrance
makes way for a small breeze damn it's hotter than i thought
can't wait to get home and take a shower i wonder who that
girl was seems like she already left she must have been in a
hurry
yeah if we're the dorm what else can i go do hey chid ho
what are you doing campus miss school too much during your
break i could ask you the same thing i took a a summer job
at a coffee shop i could really use a summer job i don't
have time my mom forced me into this i can't i'm still
transferring i'm still transferring we'll never know the
ending What the hell did I bring?
Toki, it was getting good!
Oh my god, wait.
Fish with knives at 20?
Alright, wait, oops.
Alright, let's see.
Summer day, live fish with knives.
Oh my god.
Bark, bark, bark.
Wait!
Is there a dog in the fish game?
me wants to go out should i take her it's okay i can take
her for you let me just finish up this part real quick no
please i've been bothering you enough all day i'll take her
again i don't mind but it's night out now it's really not
safe just go around the park it'll be fine okay be careful
i'll make us something when you get back thanks honey love
you too
Guys, I think the fish game has a fucking dog in it.
Should I be okay?
Oh, okay.
What's wrong, Nina?
You see something?
Nina, what do you see, Nina?
I'm having trouble seeing where you're going.
Keep going.
I mean, that's the only option.
You hear the still water of the lake.
Okay.
You notice you can't see Nina anymore.
Can't see anything.
Decided to keep going.
Oh hey, a stone!
Okay.
Okay, we got a stone now.
okay uh okay um it's okay guys we have nina nina is in the
game now guys it's okay
all right infuse
oh here's a stone oh i can't put up the oh oh the game is
lagging Nina turned into a stone guys Oh
wait the game starts now Let's go 1974 CTF Gorge Oh okay
There's a plot in my shooter now Oh oh it's water Okay they
added water Oh cause of the lake
I love CTF Gorge Oh Oh my god, we have story mode now.
A pool of water bridges an unfriendly gap.
Feelings of sitting in a lake with friends stir up inside
you.
Look, there's fish.
Watching from across the lake.
The fish?
Look, it's the fish with knives.
Oh hey, there's the flag.
Oh, it's bugging out.
The flag rests in an unfamiliar place.
Why here?
Yes, visual novel, FPS.
Actually, I think there's a good reason.
The other one's just playing messy.
It was up to him.
The whole map will be underwater by now.
Wait, who's him?
Wait, why can't I get the...
Hello?
Is there any flag on the other side?
Oh.
At last, the player reaches the blue base.
The flag.
Oh no, this is all wrong.
I'll talk with the other one.
He's hard to talk to.
Oh, look.
See, there's the fish with knives.
There's the fish from fish with knives, guys.
Oh, no.
How do I get out of here?
Does that mean I can get the flag now?
Should be allowed to claim the flag, right?
No?
I mean, I guess I'll just go back.
Because I can't...
Oh!
Is that someone over there?
Am I tripping?
Oh?
No, that's just the graphics, right?
Tower and structure are sunk to the floor.
The player realizes there's an interfering party.
Nevertheless, the player marches on towards the blue flag.
I'm already there.
What do you mean?
I already went over to the flag.
Anything over here?
Hello, fishies.
The player remembers music.
This isn't what they're expecting.
If I'm being honest, I'd like to have some music.
I didn't do this, of course.
There's three of us here now.
Well, four are counting you.
At least we're up here.
Oh, hey, there's more fishes.
Oh.
A thick sheet of glass is separating the player and the
fish.
Looking in their eyes, you sense a sense of relief.
Wee!
Alright, reset.
Does that mean I can get the flag now?
I should be allowed to get the flag.
I feel like I got all the dialogue.
Hello?
Am I allowed to get the flag now?
Oh, wait.
Just like the classic.
Oh, it's still not possible.
That's weird.
I might get shoot the fish, though, at least.
What if I'm supposed to play it?
Just like in real life, I know.
Don't you hate it when your fish explodes after you shoot
it?
That's the worst, guys.
I think that's it.
That's all the stone did.
I don't think there's anywhere else to climb.
Okay, yeah, that was just a map.
It wasn't actually a ghost.
Thank God.
I mean, I could climb that, right?
Does this lead anywhere?
I don't think it leads anywhere, though.
I could try.
Yeah, I broke the game.
Wee!
Oh!
Yeah, I think that's it.
Alright, I'm leaving the game.
We gotta add another stone in here.
Okay, I guess I'm not leaving the game.
Yes!
Uh...
Um...
Okay, so...
Oh, yeah, I saw the crate.
Yeah, yeah.
Gabe says no.
You can't leave, Doki.
Do I have to find Nina?
Nina to die?
There was a crate over there.
Yeah, I saw that, but I didn't think I could go through it.
Oh, what?
Oh, never mind.
That's awful out of bounds.
Never goodbye.
Goodbye?
Oh.
Hello?
Wait.
That's...
Oh.
That's a flag.
Right there.
Guys, oh, oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
Oh, oh, I don't like that.
Oh, I think, guys, do you think he sees me?
No, right, guys, do you think he...
No, he doesn't see me, right?
He doesn't...
Oh, but there's a flag right there.
It's okay, I don't think I'll just slowly swim to the side.
Must capture fly.
I don't think he sees me right oh I'm very slowly going to
the side who's like literally capping the flag right now oh
my god I swear to God I'm swimming fucking forever for this
flag no he's gonna kill me no there is no way I'm not making
it to this flag I'm definitely not making it the moment he
sees me I'm a gun what are you guys i don't think my fucking
measly fucking gun ammo bullet is gonna fucking do anything
to him i'd be very surprised if it even pierces the goddamn
fins um the fish explode just make him explode toky am i
getting closer is that even a fucking fly
even tell is that even a flag at that point like what is
that over there what even is that
guys i don't think that was a flag guys that does not look
like a flag guys i do not know what that is am i even
getting closer to it
oh he doesn't see me guys he doesn't see me
Oh, oh, I made it.
The player stands in a room with a wooden door.
The clock ticking.
A carpet with a familiar smell.
Grassy lawn circled the concrete pillars.
Seem only a distant memory now.
Open the door?
No.
Oh, okay.
Oh?
Where am I?
hello oh this game is buggy as fuck right now oh okay oh um
parkour
oh oh oh this game does not look like it's okay oh okay
Is this okay?
Is this game okay?
Oh, it feels like the coder stopped working on this game.
Yeah, where's my gun?
What happened to my gun?
Where the fuck do I go?
What if I just walk away?
Oh, I can't walk away.
Oh, man.
Don't you hate it when they update a new patch and it breaks
everything, guys?
That's the fucking worst.
I don't even know where to go.
Oh.
Oh my god, this game is so fucky.
I'm so lost.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Where do I go?
We live here now.
Can I leave?
Nope, nope.
It's okay.
Maybe I can just, you know, turn off my PC.
Do I just stand in this room?
Maybe I just stand in this room.
I don't like this.
Maybe something will start loading.
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, do the rectangles need to line up?
Oh, there it is.
No, it's not finished yet, of course.
I see what you're saying.
It's not that I don't agree.
It's just a process, you know?
Okay.
I don't like it when you comment about my work before it's
done.
How would you feel if I did that with yours?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, now I have to line this up.
Oh, hey, there's a woman there.
I mean, there's a person.
Well, I don't know if it's a woman, but...
Line up.
There you go.
Oh, okay.
No, it's Okay, really.
Don't worry.
I have stuff I have to do downstairs.
You can have the room.
Don't assume.
I just don't want to talk about this right now.
Just stop helping me for the rest of the day.
Oh.
Are you guys okay?
I love you too, honey.
I'll see you later.
Oh.
Okay.
Guys, I fixed the game, guys.
Look.
Oh, oh, there's another room.
Oh, the room fixed itself.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, that's so trippy.
You really cut it like that.
It's weird.
I've never noticed.
Hmm.
Is it weird that sometimes you feel like a new person to me?
No.
Don't go look at me like that.
I met in a good way.
I'm sorry.
Are you sure?
I can run out and get some and it's fine.
Really?
Thank you so much.
I'll just, like, it's simmered down for now.
Oh, it's like memories from like whoever died.
Can we talk about tomorrow?
I have to get up early tomorrow.
Yeah.
I'm meeting with my agent again.
Oh, you know?
She wanted to go over Ditas with a retrospective.
I added some cold water so you can drink it right away.
Don't worry.
It's not from the tap, I promise.
Oh, okay.
Oh, this is a new room.
I don't want to be alone right now.
Why don't you understand that?
I know you need that.
It's just, I don't need that right now.
I'm just saying that.
I want you to be able to do your thing.
I don't worry about you spending so much time taking care of
me.
It's just, I don't want you to be responsive to you giving
everything up.
Oh, they're dying.
on how can we be married if you're upstairs and i'm
downstairs all the time i don't mean that literally you
understand that right oh is this about sarah was sarah did
sarah have a terminal illness i do care about your work it's
just it's so different i can't really understand what you're
doing you know i don't know how to help you and you don't
have to help me i have her for that.
Oh.
Stairs time.
Oh, they fixed the upstairs.
Guys, they hot fixed it.
New patch out.
Upstairs is fixed now.
You're keeping me downstairs?
What's the point?
You didn't even make the second floor.
You don't need to be so transparent.
Why are you always talking about me?
What's going- why are we still not talking with- Where have
you found me?
What are you- why are you keeping me in your work?
What is this place?
What- Okay, okay, okay.
To you, is anything I'm saying getting through?
Oh, this is where I walked Nina.
I remember this.
This is a doggy soul.
Hello?
Ooh, this is getting trippy.
Rocking a ghost is so fun, guys.
No trauma here at all.
Oh my god.
Where am I going?
It's procedural generated too.
This game has everything.
Why is the music getting spookier?
The more I walk.
Oh.
I did it.
I procedural generated a link.
It's like jump.
I don't want to jump.
You're like, Doki, you're supposed to jump now, okay?
Oh?
Listen to the music, Doki.
Jump into the red lake!
Oh, hey, we're back in the game.
We did it!
The game is just...
A window...
Look within.
Find me.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Now the game has a sword.
Has a dog.
Oh.
Is that?
Thanks, Sarah.
Guys, these malware is getting crazy now, guys.
Oh, my God.
You know, oh.
Sarah's studio.
Oh, I didn't think I was actually drying.
Did I do good?
Yeah!
Hey, I did real good.
Clear.
Oh yeah, it had 10!
Oh, do I have to let...
I don't have what?
Oh, this is what.
And then...
Where's my signature?
There.
You're smelling the nose of flower.
Yay!
Man.
Sarah.
Did I do it?
What a fun little game.
Yay!
Can I only get 8 out of 10?
What a masterpiece.
Yeah, mood.
Oh, you don't worry.
There's flowers here.
There we go.
Does that give me 8 out of 10 as well?
It's just going to give 8 out of 10 all the time.
Yeah.
There's no other score.
This guy only programmed this game to give me 8 out of 10.
Alright.
Do I infuse it with this?
Generate.
Wait, I got to generate a new host.
Give me a sec.
My Satan Dark Arts app needs to have a new host.
for this.
I assume that.
Maybe Mind Sweeper?
Oh my god, what the fuck is in?
Sarah used to love Mind Sweeper.
Alright.
Mind?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Mind friend.
Friend shape.
What happens?
Does he die?
we don't do good like does he like die yeah that's the game
yeah okay apparently if you infuse these two games together
it just becomes a funny silly game all right no it becomes a
little silly okay dungeon blade what the what kind of game
will this mate.
Yeah, for the dragoons.
Yeah, thank you, Super Chat Labby.
Thank you, thank you.
When you're faced with a blank canvas, you paint waves
before you paint the storm.
Okay.
Oh.
Huh.
Alright.
I have the Power of brush on me.
Paint!
Bam!
Painted.
Get painted.
Oh.
Friends and family.
Okay.
Alright.
Very abstract, Sarah.
Is there another one?
What a masterpiece.
It's just easy.
that painting is so easy guys should be forgot slap your
brush onto a canvas and BAM two million dollars laundering
scheme for those who don't know a lot of art gallery shit is
just a fucking money launder distant places I'm Picasso yeah
Like, you'd be like, how the fuck did this sewed for $2
million?
But it's just peeped billionaires trying to money
laundering.
Wait, what?
Why can't peep this?
Oh, there it is.
Feels like home.
I feel like Sarah might not be a very good artist.
Alright, here you go.
Now what is this?
Brings me to Sarah.
Brings me to what?
Oh, one more painting.
I'll just say I definitely would not have bought any of
these paintings.
I'm sorry, Sarah.
I just, I don't know.
There's something about that.
It's just untitled.
Oh, okay.
Now you can't even name your painting, Sarah.
What can you do?
Oh.
Is this lost?
Yeah, I'll take you with a super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh.
New stone.
All right.
Infuse time.
Okay.
Oh.
That was a very scary painting there, Sarah.
Oh, that wall.
Now my game is just red.
Like the devil.
Okay.
I think we fit a lot of souls into this game I don't guys.
I'm a little worried because it feels like this game now
might have an over a button to souls now I don't know how
many souls we put it in there Could the infinity souls are
now complete Oh I have a barrel now
Oh wait, it came back Wait, what?
Oh, that's cool.
Now there's barrels.
Do I have to do this again?
Oh, I do.
You have to put two and two together faster than people.
They know they're not safe much longer.
What does that player know?
Wait, what do you mean?
Does the player know that?
Oh, this is new data.
Oh, did you see that?
I think you cracked that.
glass.
I don't like this idea.
I'm sure the other one will get kick out of it.
Alright, let's do it again.
Oh, I can't do it.
I can't.
My bullets don't break the glass.
What?
Oh, hey.
Watch where you throw those things.
Things are already messy as they are.
Although maybe the barrels can help us out here.
Wait, what can the barrels do?
Okay, I can move the barrels somewhere.
But where?
Okay, it's a little puzzle.
Oh, I can move them.
Can I move it up here?
Okay.
Where am I supposed to move the barrels?
So I'm moving this way?
No?
Oh, the flag is back there.
Oh, they patched the little area.
Yeah, they patched it.
Well, the barrel didn't respawn with the fishes this time.
Can I put the barrel into the...
Oh, no?
Hmm...
Another puzzle.
I'm like, where do I put these barrels?
Because they didn't respawn.
Oh, here?
No?
This is new.
Every time they come back, something is different.
You've added even more of us to this game.
The new one seems nice.
One wanted more action.
these barrels the other well the other one wants you to find
them okay who's them who the fuck is them oh maybe this no
that doesn't take it yeah souls are talking to each other
right now the souls are trying to hot fix this game oh there
we go
how the do we break the last one though Like this?
Oh, I want...
I need to figure out...
Oh, wait, maybe?
Yeah!
We did it!
We broke the aquarium!
Oh, now we can...
Oh, nice.
Now we can go to the other area.
Oh.
OTF gallery.
Okay.
Where am I going at?
New map, guys.
The souls created a new map for us.
How nice of them.
It's cool.
They programmed a new map.
Linger on the fruits of home.
Oh.
There's her painting.
Oh, that's a video.
Oh, I guess.
Oh, that's the lake with the dog.
Oh, my God.
Did the dog drown?
That's the lake.
Yeah, those are the paintings I did.
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Hey, Sarah.
What do you see?
In the painting, I mean.
I'm don't do very well with abstract art I'm not sure I kind
of see a woman with short black hair She's walking away from
the viewer You'd only see the back of her head here in the
middle What the fuck Oh I totally see it too And the yellow
around her like Street lights What the fuck Now I totally
won't be able to unsee that I actually kind of like these
abstract paintings reason every time i see this painting
i'll think of a woman walking down a street at night i mean
i i guess i i can see it i i also see a penguin in the
center like with his long ass beak
and and that way it kind of becomes something personal
someone else might see a kangaroo and that would be what a
painting is for them you really sound like you know what
you're talking about.
Oh, believe me, I don't.
I don't really go to places like this as much as I should.
You live in a city?
No.
I live way out in rain doing research at the Voskir in...
Yeah, whatever.
I come here once every month for meetings, and I try to
sneak in some sightseeing.
I live in Lichtenberg, so not that far from here.
By the way, I didn't catch your name.
I'm John.
Oh, this is when I first met my dead wife.
Sarah, it's nice to meet you, John.
Yeah, the same.
So, Sarah, what do you see in the painting?
Well, I don't know.
I don't think I should say.
John, you should tell her how you're programming your
goddamn video games.
Let me ask you something.
You think whatever the artist intended is important?
she's testing him because she knows she's the artist still
oh i hate that don't be like i wonder who did this painting
as you are the artist looking undercover maybe what do you
think i think the intent is not important you put a bigger
soul in there unintentionally and i believe that the viewer
probably sees that or feels that wait i just realized are
you the Yes, I am.
Oh, well, in that case, I have to know.
What do you see in the painting?
Well, if you must know, it's mostly crashing the...
Okay, that got me.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That...
Oh, my...
That actually got me.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I...
Yeah, I ran out of memory, guys.
There was just too much water in that scene.
My two megabytes couldn't handle it.
Okay.
But, that's been today since I'm out of my cascaded.
Oh, I had too much mesh levels, apparently.
Alright.
Oh, I can't delete it.
Okay.
Oh.
Delete, delete, delete, guys, I'm programming.
Oh, yeah, I know that's, yeah, my two megabytes was not
dealing with this.
We gotta delete the entire gallery, guys.
The entire, oh my god, there is no way.
Really, the entire gallery?
Bro, okay, yeah, yo, so, so we have two megabytes.
Nobody's running this on their fucking dial-up PC.
You have to fucking, what's the word?
What's the word to lower the size?
You gotta optimize that shit, bro.
Like, what's the point of combining all these solos into my
game?
If you can't even optimize shit.
Okay, we're almost done.
Is there still a stupid meme?
We can't delete that.
We'll just leave it here.
Compress.
Just keep compressing, guys.
Oh my god.
Am I deleting my entire map?
Okay, we gotta delete the...
The barrels.
That gets the fish, too.
Yeah, fuck the map as well.
You know, just... I don't even know if I'm deleting
everything correctly.
Okay, delete the barrels.
You know what, fuck it.
Delete the water.
Yeah, fuck this tree, too.
Yeah, fuck that area.
Because I don't think I'm doing this correctly.
You know what?
We don't need the glass here.
Oh, what?
Oh, that's me.
I'm gonna delete myself.
Look at that.
I'm freeing up so much memory now.
At memory, I'm saving, guys.
There's a gate?
Oh.
But I'm lost.
Uh.
Where am I?
Compile.
I think I've saved, fixed the game.
And I do it?
Into the void, I go.
Yay!
Explore it.
Oh.
Sarah?
What did I do to my game?
Because I think I...
Oh.
Did I delete it too much?
Pick up.
Yes.
Ooh.
Ooh, it's getting a little freaky.
Whamamam.
What is this?
Muff?
What am I doing?
Oh, it's Morse code.
Oh my god, I'm DJing right now.
I'm DJing?
Did I do it?
Did I do it correctly?
Is that how DJs are born?
I don't know.
No.
Morse code.
I don't even know what I'm supposed to do.
Calibrate, reverse speed.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Reverse speed 50.
Yeah, I was too busy jamming out to the thing.
All right, there you go.
I did it.
I like there's a text that tells me what to do.
And I'm like,
My voice
It's so clear I can hear myself again I was in the groove, I
was DJing
Putting on these records It's acting as sort of a channel I
don't think we have much time
I'm Sarah.
Or...
What's left of me?
This record player.
John.
Wait, John did this.
He put my soul in here.
Yeah.
Okay, maybe you should have married a fucking satanic
worshiper.
Maybe that's you, Sarah.
That's on you.
By tearing me loose from...
the game you somehow cleared up all the noise like popping
your ears I don't remember much I was walking I don't feel
like there'd be signs you know if you're married to a
fucking Satan worshiper that's like transmutating mutating
souls into a video game there has to be signs i woke up i
could see again everything was clear but i had no body
managed to reach me now help me reach john My time on this
record is running out.
Okay, it didn't help that I was jamming out with the record.
I'll create a new one.
Oh, hey, a new record.
We can keep talking on there.
Oh.
Nice.
That's cool.
Okay.
I can do to talk to you.
Alright.
Got another vinyl.
Thanks, Sarah.
Not too bad.
Got another one.
Oh, this is like playing.
No track playing.
Bada.
Signal found.
Tune track.
Tune.
Is this?
Calibrate.
Tune track.
How the fuck do I tune it?
Girl, I don't know.
I'm not a music person.
How the fuck do you tune it?
I just don't speed.
Morse code and tune.
Okay.
Reverse?
Am I tuning?
I don't think I'm tuning it, guys.
Alright, now your instructions are bad.
Is it the frequency?
Oh, it is.
It's green now.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
I figured it out.
It's the waves.
Having you here is taking more out of me than I thought.
I'm auto-tuning her.
I suppose.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just watch for that, too.
Absolute cinema.
Is it better or worse than the first movie?
First of all, you must be wondering why I'm like this.
Yeah, of all the things your husband could put you in, he
put you in a record player.
John, before I met him...
I was doing research into unnatural things.
Yeah, like worshiping the fucking devil?
His research was at the core of Inuit's schemes.
Everything was going so well.
Until I...
I'm already exerting myself too much.
I should stick to the point.
I've been thinking for a while On how I can reach John Oh,
the chairs are glitching out She's not strong enough to
stabilize this game It's so unoptimized I know he's trying
to find me
This is my soul Is trapped here There's not much I can do
But you You You have already achieved so much.
Yeah, I press on a file and I hit delete.
It's getting more difficult for me to communicate.
We need to be quick.
Okay, one more record, I guess.
I'm growing weaker.
This is the last battle I can create.
I'll explain my plan to you.
Oh, it's floating a wind now.
It's...
Oh, no.
the vinyl is floating away um okay um oh okay there we go
never mind okay it's okay it's out it's a little out of
balance but i got it okay it doesn't help that like she
wasted time explaining things when she's running out of
juice but the two she was like repeating like i don't have
much time like five times
all right signal found more on more code all right Morse mod
which
one oh this one there you go Sabah okay Sabah signal I'm
getting better, guys.
I'm getting better at being a DJ.
Our window is closing on us.
We don't need to listen carefully.
If we want to reach John, I will need you by my side.
Okay, less work.
More explanation.
Less exposition.
I can't think of any other way.
You have to.
Yes, what do I have to do?
upload what okay there's only so much you can do from okay
but does it have to be me if you're ready use john's tools
there okay that's a trap there is okay you want another soul
in your game all right hold on hold on hold on what do you
mean you want another soul in this game My memory is fading
fast.
You're the password to the repository is the name of my
painting.
The one that brought us together.
I'm like, good luck.
He's always was sentimental.
Old soul.
Remember the name.
This is bait.
You're bro, like, crashing.
waves.
Because it's like that has to be bait.
Like, why?
I'm just this random guy that found this PC.
New project.
Like, why does it have to be my my soul?
Oh, it's like a little demo.
Is there actually anything in here?
I just, yeah, I just want to play Fishing with Mavs.
That's all I wanted to do.
Is he in here?
I guess this was like the demo before he got all Satan-y.
Alright.
What's this?
Yeah, I just wanted mine, Sweeper, too.
Oh.
Nope.
There's the lake.
Oh, there's the creepy-ass lake with my dog, Nina.
Oh.
Try not to dwell in the spirit.
You have a job to do.
Push the boat.
Okay.
Come on.
Get in the boat.
Get in from the shed before you said, uh, okay.
Open the shed.
Alright.
That never seems to break.
Take the flashlight.
Alright, now I have a flashlight.
Let's go into the scary lake.
Yep, get in.
Alright.
My name is Alan Wake and I am alright.
I assume I have to roll my boat.
Oh my god.
To the creepy light across the leg.
Am I Gatsby?
I'm Gatsby.
Am I... Okay, apparently I don't know how to row boats.
I was like, am I getting closer?
Okay.
I'm getting closer to the creepy light.
All right, here we go.
Surely nothing bad's gonna be on the other side, right?
Yeah, do I have enough memory for the water physics?
Did I delete enough files?
Right at the spot.
This is where they found her.
Went.
They must have left.
Nina?
Nina!
Oh, Nina!
I need five pieces!
How can this game?
Oh my god.
It did have my fucking dead dog.
Oh, that's her paw.
Dina.
Oh, Dina.
What if it knows I didn't sacrifice you, Dina?
I just need something powerful and personal.
That's so...
Oh my god.
my god it actually had the fucking oh my okay this is the
only way my dog's soul was actually trapped in this game
that's so that's actually pro john that is so john that
that's messed up This is actually how you optimized your
game.
You gotta trap your dog soul into this game.
Just to make a fucking knockoff of GoldenEye!
Is that five?
I think that's five, right?
See you soon, Sarah.
okay what i would
oh my god crashing
crashing okay well i have i have oh where is it oh i don't
know where i put it okay there it is I have the star.
Where the fuck is this supposed to go?
Okay.
Okay, I have this.
Run.
Um.
Oh.
Scan file.
Oh, me.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's me.
Oh.
That's what that's I'm in a jar now.
Don't don't like that
What the fuck is the sacrifice?
What do we put in here?
No, the Nina was the star I got the star out of here What
the fuck do we put in the sacrifice?
I got the sigil I got the incantation Who are we
sacrificing?
Oh, I don't like this.
Mindsweeper.
I think I got everything.
No, that's the thing.
Yeah.
We got Mindsweeper too.
I understand.
There's still one more.
My clock?
Like, what do you want from me?
What do we put in here?
A soul may not show itself without a sacrifice.
I don't know!
Extract essence so that you may lure it.
Perhaps you need a friend to help you out.
Friend?
Am I gonna bait someone?
Wait, who am I gonna add?
Wait, Quinn.
Quinn, get in here.
I...
If I can only add Quinn, be like, yo, bro, get in here.
Didn't let me sacrifice.
A friend.
What can I do?
I'm a little confused Yeah the fucking pyramid scheme Like
bro I Yo you want to check out this other game I also found
I'm actually I'm actually stuck Is there like a friend to
help me out
Because I don't know what to put in a sacrifice
If only I can send a chain letter right now everyone to
check out this cool new game I've downloaded.
I can't talk to anyone.
No, I can't talk to anyone in the chat.
So I'm a little confused.
Also, I can't boot up the game anymore.
My game became a fucking star.
Like, what do I do with that?
My game literally became a star.
Like, I'm like,
Um...
No.
The audio player?
I don't think so.
Yeah, the audio player has nothing.
Oh.
Maybe the audio player is a game?
No, I checked it out.
Sorry, Sarah.
I'm stuck here, Sarah.
You gotta give me a bone right now.
I'm stuck.
I just don't know what to sacrifice.
Yeah, give me something here.
Yes, Sarah.
Maybe some fucking instructions would be better if you want
me to put my soul in it.
Tractor is missing.
Running this file.
We're going to render a GUI.
The slot on the right to harvest.
Oh, digital essence?
Maybe.
Nope.
Nothing is going in.
I'm just stuck on this.
Why don't I just log out?
I just, I feel like I'm logging out.
Okay, wait, maybe?
Okay, I don't know your password, man.
Sarah, I'm getting pissed off right now, Sarah.
So you gotta fucking hold my hand here.
Oh, maybe?
Maybe if I put...
Well, the name of the painting is not her password for
account.
I just want to know what fits into this.
What the fuck fits into the sacrifice?
Like, that's what I want to know.
That's the only thing I'm stuck with.
God yeah I put crashing ways but it didn't open it do I have
to find another dog like like Sarah you're not helping I
don't think I could find another dog Sarah
maybe there was something in here the new project
Was there something here that I was missing?
Because this was the only thing in the game fest?
That, like, I didn't get anything out of.
I don't know if I'm supposed to get anything in there.
Oh, maybe I merged with this project.
Oh, you're right.
I could merge something with this project.
Yeah, you're right.
I'm going to try.
I think I couldn't.
I remember I couldn't.
Generate.
Yeah, with Mind Sweeper.
The classic.
Oh!
That's what it was.
Oh.
Hi.
My name is Mind Friend.
Oh.
Oh, God, you said it.
Why do I have a gun?
Oh, don't shoot.
Oh, is this for extracting essence?
Good idea.
This will be much easier than last time.
Ah, there's the extractor.
Oh, oh.
I'll just sit here.
Oh, I can use this gun to extract essence for you.
Oh, okay.
Okay, we...
Okay.
First, we will need everything to be hooked up.
Connect the power and scan the vessel first.
Wonderful.
Everything to be hooked up and ready to go.
When you're ready, just click on me to start.
Alright, let's extract some essence.
Do I remember it right?
Last time you sacrificed some foreign post.
Oh, that's what the fire is.
Okay.
Bookmark.
Alright, time to extract.
Great.
What you should do.
Just aim and shoot.
Let's keep going.
Find some more.
Oh.
Okay, releases.
Goodbye, fishing with nuns in 20 summer days.
Let's take the whole form down.
That's right.
Oh, my god.
Bam!
Oops, well, that should do it.
Alright, so, uh, the form is currently down.
We're getting DDoS right now, but we're currently getting
DDoS.
more keep sacrificing oh goodbye notepad goodbye audio
player goodbye internet goodbye sarah's photos goodbye file
explorer goodbye chat goodbye clock goodbye soul goodbye
transfer buy this we don't need that no more we don't need
this we don't need a log out we're here forever who the fuck
needs the setting page oh my god fuck this wall wallpaper
too like what even is that wallpaper oh there all filled up
the rituals have been concluded perform the blood pack glad
i could help see you please refill the components see you oh
What the fuck?
Oh, that's blood.
Oh.
Okay.
Which blood is this?
Oh.
Oh, it is my blood.
Oh, I'm passing out soon, guys.
Oh.
Oh, I don't feel so good.
That's a lot of blood.
Me when I stand up too quickly.
Oh.
Did I feel okay?
Guys, I don't think I'm okay anymore.
Alright, if they're going to use my soul for a game.
It better be a good fucking game, though.
I swear to God.
If this doesn't get nominated for Game of the Year, I'm
gonna haunt your ass.
It ends up being like...
Oh.
Where's the flag?
Oh, I deleted too much.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Did my soul fuck up the game?
Oh.
Oh, no, my soul made into a parkour game.
No!
Not a parkour game!
Not a rage bait game!
Not even a shooter.
It's just rage bait.
What the fuck do I go?
Not a platformer.
No.
This is the worst thing it could do to me.
My soul has made it into a platformer.
How could this do?
They do this to me.
Where do I go from here?
Oh, I assume I have to go up.
Yeah.
Ah, made it inside.
Oh, wow.
I love this dialogue box.
Did you add this?
Finally, I can speak clearly.
It's me, Sarah.
Can you take me with you?
Okay Let's walk and talk we don't have much time John will
probably notice your presence soon
Yeah If that happened to me at least give me some wall
running This place is a total mess when you uploaded
yourself We're super close to the core of the system now no
more filler no more window This is where I've been all this
time Your help.
Here?
We've everything destabilized.
Oh no, I think I jumped the wrong way.
Ma 'am.
Ma'am, I'm gonna have to go jump down now.
We gotta reset.
Alright, there you go.
Yeah, I messed up, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
I'm really bad at parkouring in my own soul game.
Where do we go, ma'am?
Of all the game genres I could make with my soul It had to
be a platformer It just had to be a fucking platformer Not
even a shooter Not even a...
My soul literally removed the gun This is a ripoff I demand
a soul refund
Here we go
here?
Oh my god, it was here all alone.
Okay.
Just this way.
Okay, where do we go from?
Oh, it was here.
Okay, where do we go from here?
This way.
Oh, there's the red paint.
Oh, there's a scary red.
There's a memory stone.
we get all of them back into the system things should
stabilize be careful like she said be careful i'm already
here oh oh oh this is a memory of them when they met well if
you must know is that john a nerd yeah you seem like a
goddess that worship satan i used to live pretty close to
the sea Sometimes during winter, you'd have these enormous
waves.
It's terrifying, but I do miss it.
Ah, I can relate.
I'm from the UK, from a small place not too far from
Brighton.
Oh, yes, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My way to see was always most interesting when the weather
was bad.
I missed those gloomy stretches of gray coastline.
Well, we're both stranded away from the sea now.
Huh, yeah.
You know, I don't have to hang around here all day.
I was just checking if everything was still in the right
place.
Would you want to grab a coffee with me?
Ooh, you're in, John.
You made the biggest mistake of your life, you bitch.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
But you did make a really big mistake, girl.
Oh, yeah, sure.
That would be nice.
Look, sorry, I'm trapped in the video.
I'm trapped in the PC right now.
It took my soul, so I'm angry.
That's intimidating.
I don't know if ours are any more interesting.
I'm sure nothing could be further from the truth.
Yeah, she didn't see the red flags, even though his game is
literally a red flag.
It's literally captured the flag, and the flag is red.
I'm sure nothing could be further from the truth.
no he's english that was all the warning he needed did you
see that too it's like i was there again at the museum like
it was replaying a memory how we met me and john you know
despite everything he's not a bad person okay i wish you
could have known him how he was before from the very
beginning it was just oh Okay, there is a dead dog soul in
this video game.
We both had our own lives and we're just curious about each
other.
And even though it all happened so fast, it was actually
kind of fun.
We were there for each other at the right moment.
And it all just made sense.
Okay, Sarah, before the Satan game.
Oh, oh, it's freaking out.
Oh, the world is freaking out right now.
Oh, no.
How the fuck do I get to the other stone?
Nope, not like that.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe they made it a parkour game.
Oh, not the camera.
I don't like this.
I don't like the camera shakes.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I don't know.
Don't!
No!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
It rearranged itself.
Where is it, though?
Parkour.
Wait, but where do I parkour to?
I don't even know where to parkour to.
Here?
Where do I go next?
Does that thing move?
Well, that's not true.
Or did that thing started moving?
Okay, there we go.
Go this way or the other way?
Go this way.
Yeah, Jaw was a bad level designer, I admit.
Alright, this way.
Oh, this way.
Alright, parkour.
Parkour!
wait where do i oh this way oh my god it's so fucking trippy
the parkour section is so goddamn trippy i hope i'm going
the right way it's very hard to tell it's a yellow stone
here i gotta make sure i don't fuck up because apparently
apparently if i fuck it up sends me all the way back.
Okay, nice.
Oh, there it is.
How do I reach that?
Shoot, that's a dead end.
Maybe there's some other...
No, don't do this to me, girl.
No, don't do this to me.
What do you mean?
Or wait, I haven't... Oh, thank God.
Okay, I have an idea.
I managed to do this one before.
I think I can enable a debug tool that John put in.
Okay, it does take a lot of me, so we weren't.
I mean, you're not really helpful anyway, other than that.
Focus.
Are you debugging?
Oh, nice.
She's debugging it.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, she's using console commands.
Slash no clip.
Oh.
What the fuck did you do?
Like, what can I do?
Oh!
Oh, I'm literally...
Oh, my God.
I'm fucking hacking the map.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's clever.
I like that.
I'm actually debugging.
Okay, get that gate out of here.
Oh!
Okay, oh, okay, okay.
I'm supposed to...
Okay, okay.
I was like, maybe let me get rid of my main platform real
quick.
Alright, I grabbed it.
I thought I was going to fall down into the abyss.
I did not want to go through that again.
Oh, they're on a date.
I've been talking today with Tobias about starting a
company.
And it seems like he's really on board with the whole thing.
That's great.
You know, I'll support you all the way.
Yeah, maybe...
Yeah, I should not have shot the platform I was on.
Just so you know.
It's going to be rough the first couple of years or so.
starting company is always like a negative.
Like Amazon's still losing money on Twitch.
So, it took a while before we have a game we can publish.
Yeah, that's okay, sweetie.
We've been doing fine so far with all the money laundering
for my paintings.
It's not like the Institute was paying you much anyway.
I already think that we have a good shot at this.
In the long run, able to make be more stable once we get
some investments in oh my god it's a pump and dump have big
companies invest in it and then cut the and then cut
everything off and run off with all the money I'm not
worried about the money I love our life like this besides
things are going well with my work let it be real I didn't
marry you for the money for the record I didn't either
I love you.
I love you more.
Ugh, disgusting.
You're so happy.
Okay.
Oh, John.
Hey, John.
Stop what you're doing.
How did you even get here?
Oh, hey, it's John.
Look at what you did.
Wait, he's a lot.
Ever is completely destabilized.
It's like months to repair everything.
Wait.
That vinyl you're holding.
What did you do to it?
That's my vinyl now.
You have no idea what's your message.
That's right.
She's mine now, John.
She's mine.
Who the fuck am I to have this goddamn device for a PC?
I need you to do exactly what I say.
That vinyl isn't some prop.
You're talking about people's lives here.
just yeah I'm a home worker so like whose PC is it not your
PC did I build my own PC and hack into John's PC and then
like fucking copied this entire PC set up like what the fuck
is going on I can see you're ready to have two
he's still typing third one's close it's like 300 units from
your position let me make a path.
Oh, oops.
I might have deleted that.
Shit, all these asses are completely corrupted.
Oops.
Slash Vote Kick.
I nominate to Vote Kick John.
He's ruining the game right now.
Alright, there's Dungeon Blade.
Alright, here we go.
We've got the Dungeon Blade parkour now.
I removed the skeletons.
The skeletons.
And then this should open up, right?
Yeah.
God damn it, John.
Can't even import assets correctly.
Like, why are there skeletons in my... Oh my god.
And a wizard.
Alright, there you go.
Sorry, but yeah, that's right.
We're nearly there.
And you better be sorry, John.
Just deleted the enemies instead of me shooting it.
I think if they touch me, I'm like back in the beginning.
I'm not risking that shit.
I parkoured so far.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Um, John, I fucked up.
John, can you fix that?
John, I...
John, I shot the platform, John.
There we go.
John, I can't get there, John.
John, I need help.
John.
John, please.
I can't reach it.
Oh, there you go.
I can reach it now.
JK, I got it.
John.
Okay, we'll have to jump on this.
Yay, we made it!
Oh, they live in a shitty apartment.
It's cute.
God, these flowers are pain in the ass.
I should take a break.
Your eyes again?
Yeah, it gets worse when I...
I worked so late.
You should leave it for the day.
Come back to it tomorrow.
No, no.
Samantha wants me to have the series done by next week.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's a nice painting.
Siri, I'm almost there.
But your eyes are your string or so.
I'm fine, John.
It's not that serious.
That's stressful.
You should really Yeah, I checked out already.
I did.
What?
When?
Why didn't you tell me?
It's fine.
Don't worry.
Oh, whenever someone says don't worry about it.
Whenever someone says don't worry about it, I think you
gotta worry.
What did the doctor say?
Is it going to progress?
Well?
Yes, it's...
Going to get worse.
Oh, just wear glasses.
I fixed these things.
Have you ever thought about getting glasses?
Just wear glasses, forehead.
Fuck!
Okay, I was not excited.
Fuck.
But there's a cure, right?
Let's talk about this later.
I'm trying to focus here.
Oh, there's no cure.
Okay.
Aww.
What was that?
When you picked up the stone.
Someone took control of the engine.
Such raw power.
I've never been able to control it like that.
Who am I?
I'm...
By the way, what you saw there, those are my memories.
They're private.
It's not your business.
You are an intruder, understood?
Okay, then why did you let me go, like, make this platform
for me?
I like, she's like, you're a stranger.
You're not welcome here.
Anyway, here are some platforms, and the next stone is not
too far.
Just keep picking up the stones.
Then we'll be done here.
And you can leave.
Yeah, I like how he's like, he's like, you're an intruder.
Let me help you make more parkour maps real quick.
Alright.
Yay!
Oh.
Mind friend.
Hey there.
My name is Mind friend.
Wait.
Mind friend.
What are you doing?
I think this intruder is trying to steal your gems.
Don't worry.
I'll take it from here.
Mind friend.
No!
Mind friend!
I played so much Minds.
You can't just do this to me!
I saw them logging into your camp.
At first, I thought it was you.
But then they started using all your tools.
I don't understand.
What about all the minesweep?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, they kicked mine, friend.
They kicked them.
That's right.
Get kicked from the lobby.
I both kicked you.
My friend was actually one of my...
Oh my gosh.
No!
I'm fusing to game survives.
I made it a bit messy.
Okay.
Okay, now it explodes.
It did not explode before.
Okay.
Okay, got this.
I knew I forgot to reload.
Guys, reloading is very important.
I told you, this is exactly why I didn't want to get hit at
first.
Oh my god, it's a fucking...
No!
Oh my god, a fucking corner jump.
Oh my god, what is this fucking Minecraft parkour?
Parkour civilization?
I can't believe they parkour civilization, me.
What the fucking corner jumps and everything.
Okay.
I'm just gonna destroy the plow.
Destroy the wall.
Oh, no.
Where am I supposed to go?
Where did my friend take the guy?
Where did he take it?
I'm...
I'm confused.
views oh it's here okay oh there it is god damn stupid mind
friend i thought i thought we were cool i thought we cool
oh okay thank god okay that's scared me all right nice
hello oh she drowned herself
oh cuz she couldn't see what
was that it can't be that's not my memory I was never there
I never saw it happen what did you do whose memories that
you infuse my memories, John.
When the player put those stones in, it took a part of me
this time.
Sarah!
You think you can talk?
I can't believe it!
You're a wonderful, wonderful person who figured it out all
these years!
It's good to hear you, John.
It's been a long time.
this is incredible we have so much to talk about so much I
wanted to say so much left unsaid I'm so sorry for
everything that happened it's all right John I know it
wasn't your fault I what happened is not important but we
need to talk what am i doing here of course yes i'm like the
third wheel right now like what am i doing here like first
the player has to pick up the last stone then we can get
back to normal normal oh she's a fucking record look at look
at her look at this place this is normal to you we have to
stop all of this.
The player is going to pick up the last stone, and then
we're going to end this.
Sorry, no, I built all of this for you.
Finally, you're stable enough to talk.
And now, you're just going to throw that all away?
That's not what I want.
I never asked for any of this.
I'm sorry, but it needs to end.
What What are you doing?
Oh, she's extracting for Sarah.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, Sarah.
Sorry, let's just talk about this.
Don't worry.
We'll figure this out.
That's right.
Sarah's coming with me, John.
Well, this is it.
I hope...
is okay for you, Sarah.
This was your favorite one, after all.
God, please make this work.
John, what happened to you?
What have you become?
This isn't you?
But I got so close.
All I wanted was to see you again.
And it worked.
you're here i'm not here i've died i've accepted that and
then you included her dead dog it's time you accept that too
but you're not dead we're talking you're alive what am i
right now it's neither alive nor dead i'm in your game here
to steal your girl it's not right keeping me in this state i
want out john nothing about this is normal
yeah john this is absolutely not normal and also what i'm
doing is absolutely not normal you shouldn't be here
couldn't get yes target isn't a player why can't i kick you
from the game
That's right.
Stop!
Just let me do this, John.
Rex X to confirm.
This action cannot be done.
It's for the best.
No, you can't do this to me.
You're doing this to me.
Is anything I'm saying getting through to you?
I want out.
It's time to end.
this.
Oh my god, I'm going to capture the flag, guys.
Okay.
Press X.
Wait.
What?
What does that mean?
Is this really what you want, Sarah?
I built all of this because I thought it would fix things,
but nothing was broken john i was happy with you
but then why did you have to go why did you have to leave me
alone i i don't blame you for what happened but i'm dead
john being stuck in your game doesn't make me alive to be
fair he did put her in an in a captured of that game when
she's an artist.
Like, if anything, if he had programmed a game that was
about art, maybe she would be happier.
The system cannot dispose of your soul without a
replacement.
Otherwise, it won't be able to complete the operation.
Do you realize what you're asking of the player?
Oh, God.
I'm so sorry If I had known then Fucking you I knew it,
bitch I knew it I knew this was a trap Grab the flag to
upload yourself
But if you go through here You'll be back at your computer
And you can forget I'm not even going to let you finish I'll
be like Okay.
Are you really going to sacrifice yourself for someone you
don't even know whenever you're ready?
They immediately rushed in the car.
Yeah, I'm out.
Um, look, Sarah, like, I'm, you're dead and I'm not dead.
I, I, it's, it's, it's.
She's already dead, guys.
And I'm not.
So.
Peace.
Another right end.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Sarah, look, girl.
I'm not dead.
Yeah.
Uh, I did it!
GG, Sarah.
I mean, yeah.
That's true.
We're alive!
You did all of that just to walk up.
I'm alive.
Yay!
He was right, though.
He was right.
I mean, like...
Why...
I mean, Sarah was already dead, so like, technically, like,
what am I doing at that point?
Like, I could still live on.
At that point, like, I, you know, I could get out and then
whistleblow, you know?
Eternal Damnation for Sarah.
I'm so alive.
I could still get his game shut down, guys.
Print.
Localization.
That was an interesting game.
Um, I remember reading the ARG.
Yeah, I could literally call the police on him.
And everything.
Because I live, Sarah.
Like, Who's gonna stop him from doing this to other people?
Now that I got out of the PC, I can call the cops on him.
Call the Sabbath, please.
I know, like, I remember reading the ARG, and it was
interesting that they implemented the things in the ARG into
this game.
But I also liked how, like, they made a lot of mini-games
into this game.
I was a little confused at first, but as the game started,
going on it like you know everything started like clicking
together like all the piece all the story points started
piecing together it was less horror though I will say this
is not a horror game it's definitely a thriller there was
some really good jump scares though the fucking no the what
was it the crashing waves jump scare that one was good what
ARG is based off it's the same one no players online let me
just tell cops if this weirdo has a deceased wife in his
computer.
That's just sure to get him arrested.
But stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There were some moments, I will say, like, it felt like it
did draw on too long.
There were some moments, but, like, things did start
clicking together.
I think I could tell what, like, because I did see some
negative reviews for this game.
But, like, it's because, like, they didn't know what they
were expecting because they thought it was going to be,
like, the original no players online because no original no
players online was very horror focused but this one was more
of like like a thriller mystery versus a horror game so I
can I can see why like people who went in here being like oh
I wanted a horror game but they didn't really get a horror
game um but I think I the story was really interesting
yeah thanks for playing
oh oh the game just turns itself off the game just turns
itself off okay you know i want to know what the other
ending is like though i'll check it out no players online
ending all right there is a true okay wait no players online
wait all endings there's no oh a full playthrough okay all
right all right what is the what is the other ending for it
is it less anticlimactic
what is it like they're like oh what you gonna pick okay is
he gonna get to flag what happens oh this person also went
for the door first oh that's he also went to the door first
guys all right the flag ending I wonder if it like draws it
out longer what the fuck oh I did the bad ending oh no yeah
here wait that's it oh my they were both anticlimactic the
good ending was like him getting the flag and it was like
and then it's just black screen like like no i'm not even
gonna show it like i i can't even i'm not gonna it's that
it's it's actually so anticlimactic it just ends it
literally is like okay i'll play this i'll play it for you
yeah it's this just as it's okay the end uh yeah look this
is how it sounds and
then it ends And then it plays the credits.
All right, both endings.
The both endings are pretty anticlimactic, I would say, for
sure.
I think, yeah, no.
I love how nobody who's played this game chooses to
sacrifice themselves at the end.
Like, no, I'm not sacrificing myself.
But it was interesting.
It was an interesting game.
I do, I like, I felt like the start felt really slow after
like the original game portion of the original map.
Like, sorry, Sarah, but like you're dead.
I'm not.
I am, there are some plot holes because I'm like, who am I?
Like, hey.
because like clearly my pc was not john's pc like not john's
pc so i'm like who the fuck am i i was so confused because
like i i first i was like am i john because i could log into
john and sarah's accounts and and then but then like i was
talking to quinn as if i was like i don't know what this
game is so I was like very confused because like when I was
talking to Quinn in the beginning I was like what game is it
and everything I was like not really sure what that game is
and then but then like then I but I have access to like am I
a fucking hacker like like yeah and apparently my PC build
um fucking sucks blood out of yeah has a sucked the blood
out of your body uh option built into my pc for some fucking
reason so like like was i a fucking scammer like i took
control of john's pc and cloned it and then let's try to
steal his game company secrets like what fuck who am i uh i
was so confused at that like that was the biggest plot hole
for me because i'm Like, who the fuck am I playing as?
Yeah, oh, yeah, Blood has very natural cooling, guys.
I don't know if you know this.
Yeah, am I a vampire?
Like, because then I realized, this is not John's PC, so how
could I access John's things?
Unless it is John's PC, and John is, like, on some fucking
laptop, and he has a business overseas, his house and start
playing video games at his place like like you know john is
actually on business overseas and i'm just like a squatter
at his apartment or some um so yeah that's just like my main
gripes that i was like really confused with because i'm like
who the fuck am i playing as uh but other than that i think
the story was really interesting the jump scares got me good
um the jump scares did get me good though like the one they
did have like scares in but they're not good it was an it
was an interesting game um um it was interesting how they
expanded upon the arg of no players online and the original
indie game because the original indie game was very was like
it was the same map but it was a lot scarier it was i
remember it being a lot scarier because there was more jump
scares to it um um so um it was interesting to see how they
expanded upon the original.
I didn't watch, I didn't play the original game.
I watched Game Grumps play it, because it's like a really
popular Let's Play on their channel.
So I watched, back then, I watched Game Grumps played it a
long time ago.
this game also has an ARG going on.
Oh, that's interesting.
That's interesting.
I wonder what the ARG is for it.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
True mystery is Quinn messaging you before you connected to
the internet with a dialogue i know i was like who the the
did quinn and got my apparently i was on the forums i was
like a guy who was on the forums a lot oh my god am i the
guy that made fish with knives thank you for the super chat
guys thank you thank you um anyway i'm gonna call it here um
we do have another stream later tonight in six seven eight
nine um in four in the four hours i mostly might just do
work stuff um and most of the like trashed up on some work
as well during the good night drag rumors but we'll see
we'll see how it goes and guys i'm gonna call it here um i
hope you guys oh yeah why did quinn never showed up exactly
where the fuck was he i created a room and everything where
was he
that bitch where did he go
I'm gonna call it here.
Yeah, I know.
He's like, download this game.
Let's 1v1.
And I'm like, okay, that's fine.
That's like, that's like, go.
Yeah, and then he, he, you ghosted him for my sleeper.
So he ghosted you.
Bro, I doubt, and he made me download malware.
Oh my God, I forgot.
I forgot the game had malware too.
Like, I was like, bro, what the fuck?
But I downloaded this game and you gave me malware.
I'm gonna call you guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up
and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys later tonight.
If you guys are gonna be here later tonight.
But yeah, if you're not, then I'll see you guys next time,
everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.